hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today is going to be more
dedicated to the newer players of for
honor although this can kind of help
some average players you'll see toward
the middle of the video lie but it's
more of tips for new players and how to
get better with and I kind of be better
or for honor if they're just starting so
let's get right into this the first tip
I have for you is to play the campaign I
know this seems really weird but you'll
understand in the campaign you go
through three stories the Knights the
Vikings and the samurai faction kind of
story lines but they take you through
most of the characters you don't just
pick a class and go it says like the
night campaign you start off as a warden
then you eventually move to LA bringer
then they'll start you a peacekeeper but
then you end the campaign will warden no
you don't play conquer but you play
three out of the four classes of the
faction it's it and it even teaches you
the move set of those characters it
helps you kind of get better and the
campaign's a little bit easier so it's
nothing like too hard like so like I
said it's just a little bit easier for
other players if you don't feel like
playing campaign then the next option is
to just go around and play some random
characters try to play most of the
characters in the game now don't play
all of them but I do play most of them
and it does help me understand their
move set although I mean I never play
law bring her or I rarely do I know his
moves it so I know when certain attacks
are coming or not even if like like I
said even if you don't play the
character you know their move set so you
know if they're going to swing for an
attack what you can do the next one is
even if you're having trouble doing that
go to go to watch twitch streamers or
youtubers i'll leave the link in the
description to a spreadsheet somebody
made on the competitive for honor
subreddit for almost every character and
for honor and what people play them the
best for example we have true talent
here on YouTube who plays most of the
characters and duels and upload them on
stream and then we have praised this
praise the sun and Scott june's we play
a lot of orochi they're very good at
dark souls 2 so if you want to check
them out go for it I'll leave links to
the spreadsheet and the three people I
just mentioned channels in the
description for you all the next one is
to not get salty I know this is kind of
a weird kid but it it's a fighting game
people are going to have a lot more
galvin than you is you're a new fighter
don't get frustrated if you keep going
on losing streak maybe it's because the
character using isn't that great but
that's not always the case shugo key
used to be one of the least plate or one
of the worst characters and now he's
like top tier almost pays mattino will
start every every tournament game every
character has this potential you just
need to know it's moveset or like I said
go back to number three and then look at
some of the twitch streamers watch their
move set how they use these characters
correctly because they are very good
players number five is to play people as
much as you can not just BOTS but more
people bots are ok for at a start but
they become too predictable even I mean
yes at level three the bots are
disgustingly hard but they're too hard
for a new fire in even average players
the things are disgusting level 2 bots
are okay but then like I said they come
become too predictable later on in the
game so you want to start fighting
actual players and if you come into the
problem where you face a lot of people
with gear stats you know Rep like Rev a
gear score 108 top tier items go play
brawl or do it gets rid of all the gear
stats and all the feet so it's basically
pure skill and then I have a bonus fact
for all of you is to check the
competitive for on or subreddit I did
mention this later in the video with the
spreadsheet and that's yes where I did
get it from this subreddit is dedicated
to helping new players and even average
players such as myself with other
questions they have whether that's oh
does this attack guarantee you another
attack after this or can you guard break
someone if they if this is punishable or
not you ask a bunch of questions and
people always will respond this is like
a dedicated part of the four on or
little subreddits they have but that's
going to be really it though I did get
that is going to be my five facts and
then my bonus fact based on new
characters and what they should be able
to learn from for honor I put this out
here because it's a fighting game this
thing is very difficult just like every
game and new players are always going to
be struggling so I did how i did use
this to help them with it like I said
I'll leave a link to those three
channels I mentioned in the description
and I will leave a link to the
spreadsheet that all of you can
at if you are curious hope you all have
a great rest today guys and like I said
if you like the video please be sure to
drop a like and subscribe if you're new
guys peace out